E aí
[Música]
a vacinação estratégia mais eficiente de
prevenir e controlar a propagação de
doenças infecciosas começou a maioria
são causadas por vírus ou por bactérias
estimamos que porque vacinamos seja
salvo uma pessoa no planeta em cada 15
segundos temos a exemplo do impacto
podem ter as campanhas de vacinação a
escala Global porque foram as vacinas
que permitiram eliminar a varíola no do
planeta nos anos 80 estando prevista
para breve erradicação da poliomielite
outra doença incapacitante já só existe
no Paquistão e no Afeganistão espécies
por digital só foram possíveis porque
vacinados e porque assinantes em todos
os países desde muito cedo por exemplo
segundo dados recentes da Unicef
estima-se que 85 porcento das crianças
até um ano de idade em todo o mundo
foram inoculados com a vacina Tríplice
Pediatria tétano e tosse convulsa estes
programas de vacinação tem avançado nas
últimas décadas em 1980
o centro das Crianças tinham resolvido
recebi desta vacina mas o pessoas
vacinas e como funciona assim mas são
compostas por partículas estranhas aulas
organismo e quando são administradas ao
indivíduo provoca uma resposta
imunitária que mais tarde do protesto
contra agentes infecciosos Isto é o
nosso organismo fica preparado para
reconhecer essa gente infecciosos logo
da primeira vez que ele entra em
contacto connosco as vacinas estão assim
de uma maneira diferente os medicamentos
Porque tem uma ação preventiva da doença
e só normalmente administradas em
indivíduos saudáveis ao contrário da
maior parte dos medicamentos as vacinas
não tratam o kurumas previnem que a
doença se instala pontos grandes feitas
as vacinas é que para além do infectem o
próprio indivíduo que esses toma
Proteste também com efeito coletivo O
que diminui a possibilidade de contágio
entre as pessoas e permitem o controlo
da propagação das doenças dentro das
Comunidades tipos de vacinas tons
a bater vírus as vacinas tradicionais
são feitas com os próprios vizinhos
internos ou apenas com pedaços dos vírus
para as produzir temos que cultivar os
vírus em grandes quantidades utilizando
reatores são estes vasos que temos aqui
pode misturados todos os componentes
necessários ao crescimento das células
que irão produzir os vírus em alguns
casos também podemos usar ovos para os
produzir por exemplo a maior parte das
doses das vacinas para a gripe
ministradas anualmente são produzidas em
ovos de galinha para que não causem a
doença este vírus que constituem a
vacina tem que ser inativadas último
lacen-laboratório estes processos e
tiram a capacidade do vidro infectar e
podem então ser administrados nas
pessoas disputando a resposta imunitária
protetora estas máquinas são utilizadas
mas são difíceis de produzir em grande
escala são processos de manufatura muito
morado e corremos sempre algum risco dos
ditos puderem rebater e tornarem-se
patogênicos outra vez e não
a vacinas tradicionais são as vacinas da
poliomielite do sarampo e da rubéola
isso agora uma nova maneira de criar
vacinas com tecnologias se baseia no
conhecimento do código genético do vírus
os vírus contém dentro de si moléculas
de renal DNA que constitui o seu código
genético deste código dita todos os
aspectos da sua forma e funcionamento
inclusive as instruções sobre a sua
composição sobre Quais são as moléculas
que os vírus utilizam para se curarem as
nossas células e depois inseto e onde se
replicam cliente novas cópias de se
matando as nossas células e causando a
doença além do seu código genético dos
vírus são também compostos proteínas
Cada uma com uma função muito específica
sabemos são as proteínas da camada
exterior dos vírus sua identificadas
como estranhas ao nosso organismo e são
elas que tu é tão a nossa resposta
defesa nosso sistema então produzir
anticorpos combate
e com essas proteínas no seu exterior
por isso soubemos identifcar todas as
proteínas de um vírus aquela que gera a
maior resposta do sistema imunitário
podemos transportar o código genético
responsável pela criação dessa proteína
para o interior das nossas células desta
forma introduzimos nas nossas células as
instruções para construir a proteína do
vírus esse códigos genéticos Mr anal RNA
mensageiro e daí o nome das primeiras
vacinas aprovadas para o combate ao
convite ter ficado associada a esta
molécula minúscula outra modalidade
podemos utilizar é o código de DNA neste
caso utilizamos a deram ouvidos um tipo
de vídeo é totalmente inofensivo para
transportar para o dinheiro das nossas
células uma vez no interior das nossas
células esta apareceu lá em cima do
código genético dos vírus poeta a
produção dessas proteínas e a sua que se
pressão as telas não sentaram ao sistema
bom então fazer a resposta imunitária e
criar os anticorpos em resumo os anos
que uma parcela minúscula do código
genético de um virginal o próprio vírus
que causa a doença assassinos da renda a
mensageiro de DNA mas é na capacidade de
introduzirmos nas nossas células as
instruções para que elas próprias
construção as proteínas do vírus e essas
proteínas entram em circulação no nosso
organismo disco é tão a resposta do
nosso sistema imunitário que constrói a
barreira de defesa quando mais tarde os
verdadeiros vídeos completos infecta o
nosso organismo se conhece e reagem
diretamente tipo está aqui uma ameaça ao
ataque Intex ia sua propagação evitando
que a doença se instala seja qual for a
tecnologia que se utiliza o mais
importante é garantir que estas vacinas
são seguras e eficazes e é testado pelos
ensaios clínicos que antecedem sempre
autorização e aprovação pelas
autoridades regulatórias de
e no passado em média o tempo dura a
vamos a desenvolver entrar no mercado
com a vacina era de mais ou menos 10 15
anos isso porque era necessário passar
pela fase da descoberta da fase
pré-clínica estas duas em laboratório de
experimentação e depois as fases em
ensaios clínicos feitos já com as
pessoas os ensaios clínicos tem três
fases de aprovação a fase um onde se
testa a segurança e que é feita
normalmente um grupo quente pessoas
saudáveis cerca de 100 a fase dois onde
se teste a sua eficácia e se vale a dose
e esta já realizadas centenas de pessoas
e a faço três que envolve milhares de
pessoas que não se confirmam os
resultados das fases anteriores esse
começam incluir outras pessoas
diferentes fazer Tais diferentes raças
que ia ter com comorbilidades após essas
fases chega finalmente a fase de
aprovação que é feita pelas agências
regulamentares na Europa e nos Estados
Unidos é esse de início então a produção
em grande escala
em relação à distribuição das vacinas EA
sua administração as pessoas é uma
logística impressionantes tem que ser
ativada por podemos assegurar a
manutenção das características da vacina
do que são elas o garante a sua eficácia
a também que garantir a rastreabilidade
todos os lados a monitorização das
pessoas após a vacinação após entrar no
mercado começa então a fase quatro que
decorre durante muitos anos para só tem
usar a administração da vacina na
população monitorizar o impacto a longo
prazo da vacina EA saúde pública na
resposta a uma pergunta Mia como a
provocada pelo sars-cov dois foi
possível autorizar Os Assassinos em
tempo recorde em menos de um ano não
porque saltaram estas fases de ensaios
clínicos Mas por que algumas delas foram
aceleradas e feitas em paralelo Por
Exemplo foi iniciada a fase de produção
ainda antes das vacinas são autorizadas
pelas agências regulamentares todas
estas vacinas convite foram autorizadas
pela MP e PF
o local ser seguras eficaz nas três
fases dos ensaios clínicos no caso das
vacinas deve reinar apesar de ser o
primeiro produto que utiliza esta
tecnologia entrar no mercado tínhamos a
imensos dados obtidos em ensaios
clínicos decorrentes da utilização desta
mesma tecnologia mas para Outras
aplicações Como por exemplo o combate ao
cancro mama e de outras doenças
metabólicas foi muito importante terem
sido utilizadas tantas tecnologias
diferentes nesta corrida contra o vírus
convite porque assim aumentamos a
probabilidade de sucesso em poucos meses
não precisa ajustar unidades cervere
disponíveis no mundo todo para se
produzirem estas diferentes vacinas de
mentir o fornecimento das
matérias-primas para fazer as vacinas
dimensionar as escalas de produção
nenhum país estava preparado para este
desafio e se conseguimos hoje já termo
assinado milhões de pessoas em tempo
record foi pelo esforço cooperativo e
global de cientistas Engenheiros médicos
enfermeiros pessoal de saúde e Indústria
Farmacêutica
a vacinas tem processo de produção muito
complexo com muitas delas de base
biológica ou no caso da sino de me
enganar cremos que querem processo de
simplificação e formulação muito
complexo tem que ser desenvolvidos
processos robustos de grande escala que
possam responder à necessidade de
garantia da qualidade a gente estamos e
fazendo novos fazemos novas conquistas
diariamente mas também aparecem novos
desafios diariamente à medida que o
tempo vai passando temos que garantir
que as vacinas continuam a ser eficaz e
que as conseguimos distribuir em todos
os locais do mundo temos que
flexibilizar plataformas de vacinação
porque nem todas as vacinas são
adequadas de todas as geografias estamos
a aprender mas sabemos que esta pandemia
só poderá ser controlada através de uma
vacinação massiva de forma rápida para
diminuir a probabilidade de haver
mutações dos genes que aumentam o risco
de propagação e que vão infectar de novo
quem já tinha sido infectado ou
e aumentando a probabilidade e causando
novas sequelas
e agora O Grande Desafio de produzir e
distribuir biliões de dose levar vacina
de todas as pessoas do golo mesmo em
lugares remotos onde não há Transportes
regulares com da cadeia de frio em
setembro onde enfermeiros têm que
transportar consigo as vacinas e todos
os materiais necessários para
administrar e armazenar garantimos
sempre a manutenção da sua qualidade ou
seja a sua eficácia muitos desses
lugares remotos não tem estradas acesso
a Transportes ou eletricidade temos que
tomar as vacinas as diferentes
populações por exemplo as vacinas devem
reinar que exigem temperaturas de 80
graus centígrados negativos são para
serem armazenadas não são muito
adequadas e países africanos por exemplo
ou do Hemisfério Sul as vacinas precisam
ter mais do que uma dose também são não
são adequadas à população em Pelotas por
isso é tão bom temos tantas vacinas
diferentes e tantas alternativas para
nos adequarmos melhor terminar
Ah e por isso E além disso temos também
que garantir que a vida que estamos a
produzir Assassinas do convívio
continuamos a produzir vacinas para
outros vírus e e continuamos a combater
outras doenças porque os outros vírus se
não desapareceram com a chegada do
Convívio com a luz de esperança no
futuro podemos tornar a viver a
sociedade e partilham livremente os
nossos afetos temos Continuar a ser
resilientes e saber Esperar e confiar
que a ciência pelo seu método mostrar ao
conhecimento e as soluções para combater
este vírus e que em breve possamos que
tomar as nossas vidas eu não tenho
dúvida que as vacinas serão a solução
para travar a disseminação deste vírus
resta-nos continuar Este trabalho extra
que as pessoas compreendam que vale a
pena sermos todos vacinados para
rapidamente podemos por cobra esta para
anemia
[Música]
E aí